hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast cellular applications for
image space cytometry on a multimode
plate reader I am Judy Oracle black
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roof and sponsored by
perkinelmer perkinelmer is a global
leader focused on improving the health
and safety of people and the environment
their innovative detection imaging
informatics and service capabilities
combined with deep market knowledge and
expertise help customers gain greater
insight into their science before we
begin there are a few instructions we
want to hear from you during this
interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment you can
do this by clicking the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and will follow up so you don't
have time today you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
on the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues we'd now like to introduce
today's presenters throughout the hanalè
and maria poopsicles dr. Freud Gehenna
studied biology and achieved her PhD in
2011 at the University of kassel germany
she joined perkinelmer in may 2011 as
part of the application support team
based in Hamburg Germany the team
provides support for the multi-mode
detection plate readers to customers
sales and service within this team
welcome mainly focuses on providing
assistance on imaging and label free
applications including training and
application development Maria cuts
across studies molecular life science at
the University of Lubeck she worked on
the development of inhibitors targeting
virus replication at the department of
biochemistry of university of zurich and
on assay development for studying
protein protein interactions at the
europeans screaming port after obtaining
her master of science degree in 2013
where we have continued to work
European screening port now sound
offshore IMA screening ports and was
responsible for development of
cell-based and biochemical assays in
high-throughput screening XPS formats as
well as high content a phase in early
adme talks profiled study I will now
hand over to dr. hamil for her
presentation thank you Judy for the nice
introduction during my talk I will focus
on cellular applications for image based
cytometry and I would like to highlight
five reasons why you need imaging on a
plate reader and for that let me first
start so what is cytometry actually so
the International Society for
advancement of cytometry defined it as
the quantitative analysis of cells and
cell systems this means it measures the
optical properties of cells which are
the cell size Patel morphology the cell
count the cell cycle phase DNA content
or the existence or absence of specific
proteins on the cell surface or in the
cytoplasm for this photo site or the
saitama tree uses various detection mode
such as fluorescence or indicator dyes
or stay in this light scatter and there
are several devices available for
example flow cytometers sales orders or
image cytometers probably the oldest
form of image cytometry is the
hemocytometer which most of you probably
know yeah what can you do with
image-based cytometry so common
applications are you can't assure sa
quality you can measure proliferation or
thur immigration you can detect a viral
infection you can run cell health health
and toxicity acid can analyze
transaction or analyze fewer words or
others 3d cell cultures and small
animals and many more I would I will
highlight some of them later on so if we
talk about image based cytometry we
actually talk about it in terms of
that we have this technology on the
plate reader so for example on on our
end site multimode plate reader it
contains of conventional technologies
such as absorbent fluorescence intensity
luminescence time-resolved fluorescence
alpha technology and labor fee and on
top of that it has an hour image-based I
geometry and this is actually a so to
say a bridge between our high content
screening system and the multimode
detection world our system uses various
detecting modes for imaging which is
fluorescence imaging bright field
imaging and digital phase contrast
imaging it generates one or more images
/ well after 96 or 384 well microplate
and it analyzes images automatically
during measurement but now you may ask
yourself why do I need imaging on a
multimode plate reader and I would like
now to go through five reasons and show
you the advantages of having imaging on
a plate reader and the first one would
be seeing is believing so where you have
quality control on your plate reader I'm
a second reason is you can take new
directions meaning and you can run also
going to approaches the third reason is
it is very fast very fast imaging
technology you don't have to do it
yourself so meaning i will show you the
advantages of automated versus manual
imaging and analysis and another reason
is that you can do more for less by
using your resources efficiency so let's
now have a detailed look at the first
reason seeing is believing and it is
indeed very or sell let's say cell
biologists researchers that work with
cells are actually quite lucky because
they can visually inspect their model
system so you can always have a look at
yourselves what they are doing how do
they look do they feel a feel-good on
bad and by doing that if you have
emerging on your plate reader you can
always check the cell conditions I mean
you can pre-screen your samples for cell
seeding and self handling errors you can
verify the health status of cells during
experimental steps and as you can see
there in the images for example on the
left side the image shows a healthy cell
layer which results in a confluent e of
approximately thirty-two percent so
there the confusion see was confusion
see was determined automatically by the
imaging system in contrast to that in
the middle there was a bubble trapped in
the the well during seeding and you can
see that there the confluent see was
reduced or I'm another example on the
right you can see that the cell layer
was stretched and there you can also see
that the confluence e goes down so by
having these comparisons between wells
and confluency you can uncover artifact
of course you can also use this readout
to reduce sample preparation efforts so
you can determine cell number directly
in the SI plate I mean if you run any
other cell-based assay and you can
normalize conventional surveys as its
with this imaging data another example
is that imaging can detect artifacts
such as bacteria contamination or also
aggregating compound and what the
imaging does or the analysis starts
actually it uses the texture parameter
in the image which can detect if for
example bacteria are present or if
compounds were aggregated what you can
see on the left is there you see mcf-7
cells which are contaminated with
bacteria which you actually see just as
a gray grayish shade but the roughness
range factor on top you can see it's
much lower than on the right for healthy
cells so by you
this we are able to determine or to
detect artifacts such as contamination
or aggregating compounds or anything
else that has an influence on the
texture in the image another very common
issue I am I often observe is that we
get images from customers and they they
tell us well I expect the front section
efficiency of eighty percent I'm pretty
sure it is eighty percent but then if
you look at cells you often see that it
is not eighty percent it's way lower so
there is a good reason to to image cells
just right before your um your actually
your actual cell-based assay to make
sure what what or what amount of cells
are really successfully transfected but
I won't go into detail you because Maria
will tell you a lot more about this
later on let's now switch to the second
reason so you can of course take new
directions and use also North organelle
approaches what we have done here is we
have used several parameters or several
imaging imaging modes and also in a
conventional mode to look for cytotoxic
effect on cell so first of all we have
we looked at the same apology using
stainless bright field imaging we use
nucleus characteristics by staining the
cells in the nuclei and looking at the
fluorescence we use the cytoplasm class
make enzyme that tells us something
about its activity if it is fluorescent
and we also looked at the ATP levels of
cells and what we did in detail is so we
seeded hela cells on a plate incubated
them overnight and after attachment of
ourselves we omit them in brightfield
mode and analyze the cells then we added
DMSO which was our model component or
compound incubator cell
again and image them on the next day in
crisis mode again after that we added
sustain for the nuclei and the cytoplasm
and image these the same cells in
fluorescence imaging mode and on top of
that we removed part of the supernatant
added adp light kit solution to
determine the ATP levels and resells
bioluminescence and here you can see
some example images of the bright
freaking fluency analysis and what you
see on the left is our untreated cells
after 20 24 hour incubation there the
confluence II is pretty good at
sixty-five percent in contrast treated
cells with PMS all have a confluence II
of twenty-nine percent which is mainly
due to rounding or roundup of the cells
so here you see that you can easy easily
apply the analysis automatically and it
discriminates between empty image areas
and areas covered by self automatically
the fluorescent imaging on these cells
look like like these images here so on
the upper upper row you see the
untreated cells I'm either stained with
hooks or calcium and an overlay of both
and the lower row are the DMSO treated
cells and what you see that the
untreated cells have a very homogeneous
nucleus and cytoplasm staining and the
treated cells show very intense pain and
small nuclei and only a few cells are
positive for the calcium stain and these
cells were examined using a preset
analysis method on collider which is the
software of the N side plate reader and
what it does and detail is what you can
see on the left and the first image is
that first the nuclei are detected via
the nucleus dangers which you could
which is indicated here by a white ring
around the nucleus and then a second
ring structure is actually
produced around the nucleus and this
ring structure analyzes the intensity of
the cytoplasm stain which is now our
case to Kathy a.m. and if you apply this
analysis to treat it and not trees
itself to get an idea what's happening
with the with the nuclei and the
cytoplasm stain and in the end we ended
up with this with this table of ec 50
values so we purdue all we evaluated the
cells with dose response curve and there
you see that in some cases we have very
similar easy 50 values but in other
cases for example for the side of
cytoplasmic stain the calcium there that
you to 50 values are much lower and what
you can clearly see it is here that
depending on what parameter you use or
at what detail of apoptosis for example
you look at you see that there are
differences and in many many cases it is
known that for example if you would run
in ATP analysis only there it can happen
that compounds interview with the
biotechnology and sorry with it with the
biochemistry and in this candidate make
it can make sense to also look at these
cells with imaging another reason why
image-based utama tree is very helpful
on a plate reader is actually because it
takes almost no time and very very fast
and this is mainly based on the short
measurement times that that the imaging
technology has so as you can see on the
right for 96-well plate we need less
than two minutes and 404 384-well plate
we need less than five minutes and short
measurement times are combined with
automated image analysis during
measurement and because we work in
high-density marketplace this is also an
advantage in terms of saving time and
money so um yeah the combination of
these points leads to a minimization of
services during measurement of the cells
and probably men of many of you remember
long microscope sessions where you
actually had to examine one sample after
the other or well by well you can
amplify these time savings and
applications which involve the analysis
of multiple time points so if you run
kinetics and you can quickly test
multiple FA conditions and power earlier
but this is also something where we will
talk about in more detail a nice example
of fast imaging is also working with
small images we stop sorry with small
animals because these are often still
analyzed manually and what you can see
here is an example image of two
transgenic zebrafish embryos in a
96-well plate and but you can see so we
applied brightfield and gfp fluorescence
imaging and what you can see one of
these embryos is a successfully
transfected with gfp and the other is
not and we used here a custom image
analysis method and this method revealed
that the object coverage is eleven
percent which is corresponding to two
embryos here and the fraction of the
fluorescent area is fifty-seven percent
so which means that one of the embryos
is positive for gfp so the benefit of
the analysis here is you can verify the
gfp expression automatically in zebra
fishes and you can quantify the object /
well another advantage of the fast
imaging is also that you can run or
easily run image-based proliferation
assays so what you can see here are
fiberglass and smooth muscle cells which
were is which were not treated at all or
tweeted with the proliferation
suppressor and we periodically
determined to confluency over 50 hours
you and
and this can be easily applied to any
cell-based assay so that you either
either you use it as a main as a result
because you want to measure the
proliferation of cells but you can of
course also use the these results as a
starting point so to say for another I'm
selesai so for example if you say ok I
will have to wait until my confluence
you reach its ninety percent and then
you can track that with the imaging
module and can start your essay and here
it's really in a nice advantage to be
able to determine the confluency and
number of cells with a bright feed mode
or digital contrast mode where you don't
stress yourself at all the fourth reason
for image-based cytometry on a plate
reader is that you don't have to do it
yourself so meaning there is automated
image analysis available and this one
here the viral infection or the black FA
is a nice example from from a customer
and they're what you see on the left are
actually infected cells and whenever a
cell is in fact is you is a or the virus
produces a plaque in the cell layer
which and the plaque can be seen here on
the left in green so the viruses are
stained with an antibody and the
fluorescence black represents a number
of infectious particles on sample and
using the automated analysis you can
count these plaques automatically and in
the past these customers they were not
able to do that automatically and there
several people were counting these
plaques manually in which yeah and you
can see here that it is quite huge
advantage in terms of workflow that is
used here another essay that we have run
together with the formal farm institute
is the fully automated or
cell migration si so this horas SE
migration si is an essay where you first
put some Stoppers into each well of the
microplate then you see the cells and
let them settle down and the cells are
not allowed to attach to the area of the
stopper and when you want to start your
migration essay then you remove the
stopper and the hole in the sale layer
is left and this whole can be analyzed
automated automatically by our imaging
you see that on the on the cell picture
there and what it does it automatically
detects the cell-free area in the center
and then determines the confluency in
the center area automatically and I'm by
doing this you can then determine San
migration of several cells or interns or
in when your yourself treated with
different compounds and what you see
there in the dose-response is that you
can or a result of this analysis is for
example the gap closure velocity which
can be used as an indicator for
migration we in our on our case we have
really fully automated this essay so we
use a plate handler workstation which
transferred the plate every two hours
from an incubator to the instrument
let's now come to the last reason which
is it as you can with image-based utama
tree you can do more for less by using
your resources if it is efficiently and
what I mean by that is for example that
you can free your high content system
for more advanced work so whenever you
have high content images of course
biologically relevant increases the
content increases but also the cost
center time and by having image-based
cytometry on a plate reader you can use
this plate reader actually to to to run
read out at a lower level and then move
these samples
over to your high content imager usually
if we do oh if we run 3d cell cultures
we use the inspira 3d culture system and
this results really in very very nicely
shaped few words as you can see there on
the images from the inside and these few
words were grown in the hanging drop
which is the inferior gravity plus plate
and then they are transferred in the
gravity trap plate and this is what you
see is are there you see your recently
labeled spheroid in a Travis gravity
trap laid yeah by the way so these are
fewer words that were grown directly in
the gravity tread plates or not in a
hanging drop so there you can clearly
see the shape is not as nice as on the
images before but so we use these
spirits to treat them with fccp which is
an inhibitor of the mitochondrial
oxidative phosphorylation and you can
see in the images the FCC p
concentration increased from left to
right and the upper slide shows the
images of the N side which has a4x
objectives and in contrast to that the
lower images are from the operetta TLS
which uses them or you in this case used
a 10x lens in confocal mode these few
words were stained with TMR m which is
the fluorescent marker for the
mitochondrial potential and you can see
with increasing fccp concentrations this
marker intensity decreases and if you
then compare the evaluation of these
images of the two instruments you can
see that they nicely correlate so we
have almost the same the same ec50 value
for both these are these instruments
with the same sensors with a good good
fit so here between operetta and inside
we have very very similar results for
white peers and confocal and
and this clearly shows that you can
actually use image-based cytometry for
early early and global level analysis
but you would then hand these few words
in our example over to the operetta to
do it more advanced work to have a look
at the cells in the spheroid in detail
and so on and with this I hope that I or
that you now have a better understanding
of the value that you can you can get
having image space cytometry on a plate
reader and if you want to recap the
information so we have suing or we will
have seen a white paper available on our
inside my micro site so you see the link
there if you are interested that please
feel free to look for this white paper
there and I would now like to hand over
shortly to Judy and thanks for your
attention so far thank you dr. Hamill I
would now like to hand over to our
second speaker Maria kucik off thank you
well in the second part of our webinar
today looks like to show you an approach
for optimization of a transient row
section protocol using n side and well
before we come to the main part i would
like to give you a short introduction
about our site here in homework then we
will talk about challenges and goals of
the transient transfections after that
we will come to the final part and have
a look at the optimization of a bright
filter inspection protocol on the inside
and well last but not least i will try
to sum up all the lessons learned topic
well since 2014 we are here part of the
big front of a society that actually
part of the institute for molecular
biology and applied ecology which has
six sides here in germany and two
international ones and well our main
goal is actually to bring the academic
research and the industry more closer
together
and our main field is the screening and
as a development well as a huge part of
our screening is based on cellular
assays we of course have a lot of
challenges as a lot of experience with
challenges and goals of trans
intersection well when we have to think
of transfection what is actually mean by
that so we try to introduce a foreign
gene in the cellular system and try to
study its regulation alter the gene
product and in fact we do divide it in
two main classes so one is the stable
transfection where we integrate this
gene in a in a hostile and then the gene
remains after the replication or we can
use the transient transfection there 15
is only in the cell for several titles
were several period and it's not
integrated in a genome you can use the
various methods so for example the
biological by induction of the gene of
interest via a virus or calexico
chemical approaches with cationic lipids
or like physical md electroporation but
always the main goal is to have a high
expression of the gene of interest with
low cytotoxicity or minimal effect on
the cells especially when you're using
primary cell line and of course there
are more things to think about when you
use transient transfections so besides
the cell line or whether it should be a
transient or assembly transfection you
have a lot of possibilities to optimize
it so first of all of course the
transection conditions so which
transaction media you can use those this
cell number or the transfection reagent
on the other hand also the ratio of the
plasmid to transaction reagent or money
are using different
plasma so like more than one then of
course the ratio from plasma to plasmid
another point is because the incubation
time of the transaction complex so the
toy section reagent with the plasmid are
also with your self and well maybe also
whether you want to use the bed front
section or your transfect already plays
itself so for example in our case it's
always easier to use the bed
transcription and besides the main goal
that you have a high expression level of
the gene interest it might be also
necessary to optimize some other options
so for example in our case we normally
use the transfer transition effects it
sells for the text of compound and there
we have cost to pay attention that you
have a low place to place variability or
day-to-day ability in RSA then we have a
good quality of the essay so for example
that that prior value is high enough and
of course the issue with the cost and
time so we made a good experience with
the reduction of time by tracking
multiple quality controls parameter and
actually in the last month we use the
bright restore section allows this of
the N side to do it and what you see is
now on the next slide is the general
transactor section protocol so it's not
only a three day event on the first day
we harvest of ourselves prepare the
transaction mixture by using different
plasma concentrations or section
reagents then we mix it together and
then we you played out the cells so this
our vegetable section approach and on
next two days have been quantified the
transfection efficiency by using the
parietal transaction analysis on the
inside so what you have to do for it is
of course first of all to optimize your
exposure parameters on in
left upper corner you see that you can
choose different channels so the first
one is normally the bright field for our
normal cell detection the second one is
depending on your check off your protein
so in our case it was a GP tech so
that's why we use the blue light zone in
the middle you see our exposure
parameters well of course you may have
to optimize it for each single
experiment but this where the parameters
we used for a one else in the right
upper corner you see them the data out
where you of course select the wealth
you want to image and then below to see
two buttons for selecting the channels
whether you can so you can use the
overlay or have a look at the General
Staff working so we meant the experiment
that it all this is good to have
surprised you on the channels as you
might have difficulties to see the
signal in the other Lane then in the
next part you have the possibility to
run in automated analysis which was
mentioned very program so first of all
you select the devel or the region of
interest so by selecting the three
options on the bottom and in the next
part and you can then detect the selkirk
region by choosing the threshold
parameter then you actually do the same
for selecting get reception region and
here it's always good to have a negative
control so the non transfected selfie
then you can see easily where are your
really for the different sector cells at
the end you will get a table which gives
you the percentage of transfected cells
of course but also parameters like the
central Syrian see diminishing law or
architectural property
for example the roughness parameter may
give you a hint about how toxic you
conditions are so of course as I already
mentioned there are a lot of things
which may influence your transfection
efficiency we meant good experience by
using this report to reception matrix to
test as many conditions as possible so
in this case you have different three
different cell lines so the heck cells
have T 2 and 2 p 1 because it has three
different cell number with two different
rejection regions and three different
specimens concentration so you see you
can run really multiple parameters at
the same time so first of all we
normally have a look at how healthy are
our cells after the transaction because
normally we use pyramid use conditions
for the transient transfection and it
may already in Crean your result so for
example you see that HEK cells are but
rounded up so they are normally more
sensitive to changes in transaction
positions or like cultivation condition
in the same time you can have a look on
the cell number so for example when you
have a look at the hep g2 cells and they
took a oneself you see that too high
cell number may result in transformation
or like let's say coloring information
which may either also influence the
intersection efficiency in the next step
it's also good to have a look at the
influence of the transfection reagent
itself so also in this case you see that
the hag cells for example are more
sensitive to the transfection reagent
too and it results in the reduction of
the congruence and also the south looks
more rounded up and encountered contrast
to it be happy to sell well I'm not
really changing their morphology
when you have a closer look at of course
need it than to see clear numbers as
always to just have optically analysis
of the images you see the results for
all three cell lines where the clear
colored bars are representing the
concurrency and the spot at once the
roughness parameter as previously
mentioned the roughness parameter gives
you a hint all about the toxicity so if
it goes up then you have increased
number of rounded up stops and you can
easily see that the heck cells are has
expected more sensitive to the increased
plasma concentration so the conclusion
singles down and the roughness rarely
goes up rabbi hefty two cells and
yourself show only well lower changes in
those values in addition you also see
that lower cell number seems to be more
sensitive to changes in cultivation or
protection conditions compared to hire
cell number well of course it's good to
see that you can track the conspiracy
parameters and so have a look at the set
of toxicity of Allah transaction
promises but the main factors of course
the transfection efficiency itself so
when we have here a closer look and then
for example its own you see the
application of two different reception
reagents in HEK cells and they choke
your oneself and actually the same
transaction conditions and see here you
see that just the change of dro section
reagent can result in really high
increased intersection efficiency so in
HEK cells compared with yourself they
just ensure no difference at all well on
the next slide we'll have a look at the
real results so here's here again the
our three cell line
and now they're clear but are
representing the transaction efficiency
and the spots one the concurrency again
for the tracking of sedative visiting
also here you can clearly hear that XL
gives us the best cellular system for
the transsexual so we can reach up to
eighty percent transfection efficiency
when we use six nanogram for microliters
of our plasmid where SDFG two cells and
cho cells show only limited transfection
efficiency under ten percent at the same
time you see that when we use to
nanogram per microliter plasmid we have
the best result in all three years cell
numbers in HEK cells so with other words
that we have to we would have to
optimize the transaction conditions for
hep g2 and yourself but with egg cells
these are quite good result for the
moment well as I previously told you
that the change intersection reagent can
result really in a strong increase in
cross-section efficiency and here it's
well one more the proof of the concepts
so on the top you see the trajectory
agent one and below the results for
transfection reagent to you can clearly
see that with transfection reagent we
have really good transaction efficiency
result also we have a decrease in the
conclusion seen but on the same time
there might be a hint that with
reflection reagent one and the lowest
concentration of the plasmid we also
might have good transfection efficiency
results but when we have a look at the
images which gives us an additional
quality control and you see them on the
bottom of the of the slide you can
clearly see that the conditions for
transfection reagent to result in
enormous clump formation
and that's why giving us this putative
better transfection efficiency result so
you see that it's always good to have an
additional quality control by imaging
cure well well the first results I hope
you will see that you can use the N side
transfection graduate restriction
analysis to track and parallel the
transfection efficiency and they cell
viability in the same time you can use
the different sexual self for different
approaches so you can also run
additional essays in parallel as the
imaging is not intuitive and you can use
your optimized results for an additional
hours so as we saw previously the heck
cell line was the best cellular system
in this case and of course it is good
that you we can run multiple parameters
in parallel but it's also good to have
an additional experiment to prove the
result what to confirm the results and
here on the next slide you see a repeat
of the previous experiments so we use
the hex tile with the same condition so
they're the same cell numbers and
plasmid consecration and we could prove
that they obtained results from a
previous experiment give us nearly the
same transfection efficiency so that's
why for an hour test was good to prove
that the plate to plate and day-to-day
variability is really low and in the
same moment we wanted to see whether we
can increase the transfection efficiency
by the increase of the transaction time
and indeed when you have a look at the
different as a three different cell
number we see that by the induction of
three section time but on
24 hours you have an increase of twenty
percent of the transaction efficiency
for all three cell number actually also
achieving almost two hundred percent for
ninety two hundred percent when we use
twenty thousand cells per well and do an
anagram provider leader plasmid and the
same time we saw that the conference is
not changed so that the south are quite
happy during this conserving the
experiment yeah so that's how we
optimize the transit transfection in our
egg cell line well last but not least i
will just maybe mention one additional
possibility how you can track the
transfection efficiency so i often see a
problem that we have not checked protein
so we cannot easily track them with the
imaging so what we also use is the
presidency level transfection reagent
which increases the fluorescence when it
is integral in the Creator operated in
the membrane so normally the signal is
GP signal is of course much higher but
still with the n side you can easily
detect the amount of positive
transfected cells and in those case so
on all you have now seen that by using
the insight we can drag and parallel the
transfection efficiency and the impact
of the transaction complex so can see
the impact on the cell viability we also
saw that we can use the same batch of
transactions this transect itself and
with this nonlinear resistance methods
you can also use our transfected cells
for downstream applications so for the
real functional readout well as other
words you can really easily reduce the
time
when the effort you need for the
optimization of the transection protocol
well that's it from my side thank you
for your attention thank you for your
excellent treating patients dr. Frey
ahamill Andrea cryptic off before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window will try
to answer as many questions as we can
and our first question is in regard to
fluorescent imaging what colors can the
insight use okay this is probably a
question for me so the colors that can
be used is so we have them you can have
a mission in the UV range and the blue
green ranger and the red range a big
advantage of the inside is that we use a
triplet band set up so which means we
don't have to switch food this all the
time which is a result always which
results in a very very fast measurement
time if i get so many different
parameters and readouts from my
experiment how do i know which of these
is the right one the advantage is
actually yeah it is to have these
different parameters so it always
depends on what you what you look at
what you want to look at and yeah and
you would you would compare the same
parameter with different for different
different cells for different conditions
but you have the full picture of the
cell and how they behave under certain
conditions for their zebrafish analysis
you mentioned that there was a custom
image analysis used what does this mean
in phl and can you provide custom
analysis methods for your plate reader
yes that's that's true so we can provide
custom analysis methods so which which
means so the inside it provides preset
image analysis methods for most of our
very common epic
patient but if customers run exotic
applications which ya cannot be
evaluated with the preset ones then our
software team here our imaging software
team they can provide custom methods as
well it was mentioned that the insight
needs less than five minutes per plate
is this measurement time dependent on
the number of excitation sources and if
yes hell yes it's always dependent on
the excitation sources because if you
for example have a very low or very dim
stain then you will need a higher
exposure time so which can increase the
measurement time and of course if you
also increase the channels that are run
then yeah then if you increase that
number then the measurement time can
also increase what did the nucleus area
and the nucleus intensity tell you about
the hell absolutely sorry can you say
that again please yes what is the
nucleus area and the nucleus intensity
tell you about the shells um yo real bad
yeah maybe I can answer this question so
nucleus error gives you and about the
cytotoxicity so normally when you see a
perfect events then you have the
shrinking of yourself that you would
also see you in the nucleus you have to
pay attention and also the in a density
increases so that's why it might be that
you see higher intensity of your dying
in a nucleus so it's how I really invest
so it's like an additional from SF for
cytotoxicity how did
image analysis working detail and if it
easy to set up yeah so the image
analysis in our hands but pretty
straightforward so of course it's always
scripted when you have positive and
negative controls like wealth where you
clearly know what what you expect to see
for example in our case non transfected
cells and action you can also run the
image acquisition and then change your
analysis after what so you have
obviously the possibility to go back and
then recalculate the essay so in case
you are not true can you also do
label-free imaging I'm not sure if I
understand the question correctly I I
assume our labor free technology is
meant so and what you can do there of
course you can combine the label-free
measurement with imaging so the labor
free plates can easily view image on the
inside as well and you can combine it
which is in many cases very very helpful
to understand or to track the conditions
of the cells in the labor free plate so
they're a combination is very helpful
for your insight is like an incubator or
you need to put it in an incubator so
the instrument can be set to 37 degrees
and so you can increase the temperature
inside the instrument which you can use
for long-term experiments for example
but as we as we've shown you can of
course also automate it so automated and
put it back into the incubator and many
customers also for example track their
cells regularly and put them in the
incubator for a few hours and put the
plates back in between on the end side
and as the measurement times are so fast
that's not a not an issue with a cell
condition
do you have a software to count
automatically yes yes the software
accounts automatically know it is
possible to catch cell numbers without
nuclei staining and well I think what
your can't will be the percentage of
concurrency so it's linked to the cell
number but it's not from the direct
calculation of the cell number you might
want to use it's the insight image the
whole well in one field of view or is it
scanned with multiple fields of view it
has a4x objective and it scans the whole
well and one view so that's um yeah
that's very fast so you don't have to
set up several fuse fuse or separate yet
several refuse over well so you really
have one shot per well which makes it
pretty fast it appears that the insight
system lends itself on each image
analysis of assurance cells is there any
way to use it for cells in suspension
yes cells in suspension is also possible
of course and yeah well you just just
let yourself settle on the well bottom
the suspension cells and you can image
them as well very nicely and call them
and I'm sorry you're not into
interrupting here please no that's fine
um I will just pause for a moment and
see about additional questions coming in
and I will say okay i will say that um
see um while you're waiting too few
additional questions come in i would
like to once again thank dr. Falco
handle Andrea critical for their
presentations you have any final
comments
no not from our side yeah not really
comment but we would like to thank you
the audience so I saw we had quite a lot
of people attending so it was really
nice to have audio yeah yeah thanks for
listening and watching and of course for
moderating yeah Thank You Julian we
thank you thank you both I would also
like to thank our sponsor perkinelmer
for making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2017 you'll receive an
email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and toasted on lab
routes comm you are welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time